Oh
a great example to look at is Rico the
copier company in Japan now they're not
practicing integrated reporting they may
in the future i can't speak for what
they're going to do but i have i have
met with the executives at rico i have
written a case on Rico that will be
teaching in our advanced management
program here and Rico has developed a
what they call extra long term strategy
a 40 year strategy where they have
publicly committed to reducing their
environmental impact so it's broadly
defined its carbon its water it's you
know other emissions they have committed
to reducing their environmental impact
to 18 of what it is today including
growth so this is including anticipated
growth in the future and they have done
a very careful internal analysis and
came up with what they called their no
regret policy which was they would be
happy that they made this decision even
if not forced to do so by regulations or
by stakeholder pressure they they
convinced themselves through very
careful analysis that this was the
correct thing to do for the company that
it was the correct thing to do for
society because they're very concerned
obviously if Rico is the only company
that commits to an extra long term
planned and that's not going to change
the world but I think they're a leading
example so then the question becomes how
is the market react to my life dive
talked to people on the sell side I've
talked to people on the buy side they
recognize what Rico is doing they would
admit that it isn't being factored into
their stock price today they suggest
that over the long term as these issues
environmental and so forth become more
important that this will be to an
advantage of the company but it's the
problem that you've talked about with
Peter the sell side it's oriented six
months maybe at the out side by side
year or two years and this tension
between a two year time frame
forty year time frame is hard to
reconcile to Rico's credit they are
still doing the right thing you can
clearly say their stock prices and being
punished by it but I think if you had
more companies like Rico taking
responsibility for a longer term view
and then ultimately practicing
integrated reporting and and taking a
more multiple stakeholder point of view
then I suspect that you'll start to see
changes in the shareholder community not
all shareholders have the short-term
orientation there's ones that you can
point to largely the big pension funds
CalPERS apg Norwegian pension funds
they've been very supportive of
integrated reporting they've been very
supportive of sustainable strategies and
as they start to focus their investments
in companies that have this kind of
commitment I think you'll start to see a
benefit in terms of shareholder return